so yesterday we got to look at new
footage for the order 1886 and you
actually played it yes I did they showed
they showed a bit off on the screen
today I've got inside the PlayStation
spirits bear woman to see it's playable
inside on the show for as well but we
got a little bit of time with it out our
sort of media showcase this game is
weird because trying to communicate the
sort of pacing in this game from the now
three demos as I've played over the
course of the past year is really
difficult because what they show today
was probably one of the most fun parts
of the demo I played it was an area
where you were basically like inside a
kitchen shooting people you were using
all the guns the guns which feel really
great really interesting I'm bombastic
and of course like the setting like you
haven't played much of it but like the
setting I like the idea of this like neo
Victorian London with like steampunk and
guns and werewolves like it looks cool
yeah it's cool concept there's lots of
appealing aspects of is it looks great
settings cool and the gunplay seems fine
well it like you spend so much of the
time not shooting you spend so much of
the time being led in these incredibly
restrictive walk through the whole press
triangle use the sort of QuickTime event
on the panel to unlock the door they
show the bit of the start we are on top
of the Zeppelin and your repel against
really it looks amazing right it looks
like a cutscene it's not it's a bit of
gameplay you you're actually playing
that do you know what you're doing
you're holding up on the analog stick
you're holding up on the analog stick
and then it says press extra power and
your press X and it repels and your
press X and the repels and we're used to
tease I you know these little bits that
happen in action games to break up the
pace but most of what I have played of
that game is that type of stuff it's
very restrictive it's gorgeous but all
you're doing is basically like
interacting with cutscenes and then
every once in a while you get to shoot
stuff and that's great
and then it's back to just interact you
in cutscenes so it's really strange I'm
so interested to see this game come out
in just a couple of months will be one
of the first big games of the year of
course only on ps4 and I'm really
insured to see what that game is like to
play from start to finish because from
the demos the three demos that I've now
had exposure to its looked great it I
love the setting the gun plays fun but
most of the time you seem to be
basically playing quick time events and
you don't really have much of a say in
what's happening in the moment to moment
action sort of doing the caveat emptor
thing now because I feel like today what
they showed was the most fun part of a
25 minute demo which for the largest
time wasn't actually as compelling as
what we saw today so hopefully we'll see
more of it soon and we'll actually be
able to play that game relatively soon
so for more information on that and
everything else being shown here at the
PlayStation experience stay tuned to
gamespot com
you